many times i thought i did my best
writing and no one connected with it and
other times i had a deadline and i wrote
it very fast i thought oh my god this is
embarrassing
and people loved it
you have read like hundreds of
screenplays correct when you've interned
at these production companies you know
probably yeah what did that teach you
about writing and what came across your
desk
it's the best advice i could give any
writer
if you don't learn how to write read
script
read bad scripts which is what you'll
mostly do with good scripts as well but
um
there's no better way to write than
reading scripts
um see how different people
use the language
on the format
some people are more verbose some people
are very sparse in in descriptions
um
some people are really great i mean
scripts are not
literature they're not i mean they have
to be engaging but they're not novels
so
if you can be very
[Music]
concise
and
can convey the idea in a snappy way
in one sentence those scripts really
work
of course i mean some people have a
great prose but they're not there's not
a great story there it's it's so
difficult
because you know it's it's a conjuncture
of great story uh great characters great
use of subtext right there are many many
scripts are marred by the
by characters just stating everything
how they feel
and sometimes you got to do that but
using subtext you know good use of
subtext it's very it's always
appreciated
because we most of the time people are
not we don't go through life saying
everything we feel or think actually
in order to avoid conflict we tend
not to right
especially us to talk about couples you
know couples don't say everything to
each other otherwise they would break up
or get divorced right away
so you make a scene about something else
anyway
reading scripts helps you understand the
format and
any doubts you might have about format
like how do i structure a phone
conversation well scripts that do that
teach you
um use of language how to be precise and
concise
um how to start scenes and end them
you know some people will just surprise
you
um
every once in a while try to read great
scripts by
recognized writers as well i mean
the the script for uh unforgiven uh
clint eastwood's movie is
and that's a novel i mean i wouldn't use
it as an ex it's an amazing script
um
it's just you know
the script itself is epic
i remember the script for um
nightcrawler
is an amazing script the movie i don't
i'm not that crazy about but the script
itself
there's a use of fonts in the script
that was really original it changes the
size and type of font
just to give you an impression of la at
night and
the neon signs
and the descriptions in it are
perfect that's you know night crawler is
a perfect script
um
to analyze at least
so um
read read reading bad scripts
when you're
into an intern in a production company
and you read bad scripts
it's it boosts up your your your
confidence because you tell yourself i
can do so much better than this
and this script not to talk bad about
anyone but i'm saying this script made
it this far
especially i remember once i was shocked
reading a script that was terrible
written in five minutes and it had typos
very important
just check you know check grammar and
spelling
typos are really distracting
and everyone will tell you this you know
it shows it's not everyone makes
mistakes it's just typos show that you
don't care you know
you didn't care enough to check and you
can even use software to check that
so
reading scripts just you know it helps
you tune your mind into what it is
writing a script
do you think most new writers are overly
hard on themselves or
they have the opposite where they think
it's brilliant
i think most writers are really hard on
themselves
um
of course you'll meet a few people i
will say they're brilliant
a i don't know if they actually believe
it and b if they actually believe that
oh my god they're you know
i i i don't envy them because they're
gonna
um hit their head against the wall at
some point
um i'm not saying people can't be
brilliant of course they're
and they're they're
natural born storytellers i've met a few
it's just that you know i i don't i
don't think it's a good idea to go
through life thinking you're brilliant
sooner or later you know it's going to
hurt it forever all of us
but it hurts too to think you're not
brilliant
and in fact you're the opposite so
um you know i think we it's it'll be
good to avoid extremes
you know like
at some point i mean the older i get and
i'm not really that old but the older i
get i realize um
what helps and what doesn't help you
know it's what's useful
um is it useful to think i'm brilliant
no
is it useful to think i'm an idiot no
um
is it useful to think that this is the
best like i'm doing the best i can and
that it's probably going to be good
enough because this is what i can offer
and if they don't like it it's because
maybe i wasn't the right person for the
project
maybe um
and of course i say this very calmly now
and then i'm writing the script and i
will say to myself like oh my god this
is awful like you know i wish i could do
better
um
and i will or i will also tell myself
this is my best writing and then
you know you know what's funny um
many times i thought i did my best
writing and no one connected with it and
other times i had a deadline and i wrote
it very fast i thought oh my god this is
embarrassing
and people loved it
so
whatever opinion you have of yourself
uh i wouldn't i would try not to take
yourself too seriously
in general in life
i like that so you avoid extremes
because it also applies to dealing with
other people too oh no i'm very extreme
i'm saying what i wish i did
uh i you know i try to i try to be
mindful about it um i don't always
succeed
sure sure i mean we all want to sort of
live in the gray
but
yeah i mean
ideally if i could choose i would choose
to be
aware as aware as i can as in the moment
as i can and this has nothing to do with
writing by the way this is life i mean
um i feel like there's so many labels
that i put on myself and then everyone
puts on one another
you know and and and you're meant to
categorize yourself and
especially like what do you write
oh i write period dramas you know like
well
that's not true that's what i'm doing
now i don't think that's what i'm going
to do forever
and it doesn't help you know
i know they they need to be able to
label you so that they can hire you and
that
so you know i'm i'm not trying to start
a revolution like you know i am who i am
but um
if you have to label yourself to get a
job do it but
internally i try not to label myself
i try to be a better writer every day i
try to expand my interest
and my scope you know and if someday i
can write a rom-com why not i mean i
don't know
you